pour jean christophe cambadélis on va
parler vous parlez de la primaire de la
droite on va parler maintenant de la
primaire de la gauche
c'est une question qui va être abordée
lors du prochain conseil national du ps
le 9 avril
et c'est une question sur laquelle vous
jean christophe cambadelis vous avez un
peu changé d'avis vous étiez à la base
contre et vous êtes désormais pour avec
des conditions très précises que la
gauche toute la gauche soient
représentés dans la course mais aussi
que les perdants s'engage à soutenir
françois hollande si jamais il venait à
se présenter
bizarrement ce changement de pied il
s'est fait après l annonce de la
candidature de jean luc mélenchon qui
refuse lui ont il l'a dit d'envisager un
soutien à françois hollande
ma question aller simple est ce que
finalement vous attendez pas à ce que
les communistes et les écologistes qui
pourrait aussi participer à cette course
résonne de la même manière et se disent
on ne soutiendra pas françois hollande
et au final porte la responsabilité de
l'échec de cette primaire de précision
qui peuvent être des scoops d'ailleurs
la première c'est que le parti
socialiste a déjà lors de son dernier
conseil national dit qu'il était pour la
primaire puisqu'il a adopté à
l'initiative d'une décence il est nommé
recteur balang nom d'une des
sensibilités celle de karine berger la
constitution d'une commission de
préparation de la primaire mais pour des
raisons qui sont des raisons que je ne
pourrais comprendre je ne veux
comprendre on a décidé que le 9 avril
serait le grand moment de la primaire
très bien deuxième raison ce que j'ai
dit au point de départ c'est que je ne
trouvais je trouvais que la primaire
n'était pas le seul moyen pour obtenir
l'unité des forces de gauche aujourd'hui
jeudi
si tout le monde est loyal si tout le
monde est pour une primaire sans
préalable et sans préjugés ça peut être
une voix peut-être la plus économique
est ce qu'on rassemble avec le cas les
écologistes les communistes vont comme
vous socialiste examiner cette question
là il ya déjà des voix qui s'élèvent au
sein de ces deux partis qui disent un
soutien à françois hollande donc dans le
contexte actuel c'est compliqué et
j'entends bien mais soit vous dites que
vous êtes pour la primaires de toute la
gauche
et à ce moment là il faut accepter que
possiblement le président de la
république se présente et vous savez que
moi je le souhaite
soit vous dites c'est une primaire sans
le parti socialiste mais vous pouvez pas
faire l'un et l'autre jocaste commun
qu'est ce qui se passe après 9 avril
qu'est ce qui se passe après le 9 avril
il y aura les réunions autour de cette
primaire puisque nous allons continuer
dans ce sens et puis il y aura le
lancement de l'alliance populaire le 14
avril ces deux éléments totalement
distinctes parce que nous nous faisons
l'analyse suivante c'est que le problème
n'est pas de s'unir au second tour c'est
d'être au second tour pour être au
second tour il faut être fort au premier
tour comme nos partenaires ne veulent
pas être avec nous mais la primaire
pourrait lever cette hypothèque
en tout état de cause puisque si
françois hollande l'emportait il serait
avec nous donc ce serait un moyen de
régler ce problème de premier tour mais
comme on ne naît pas sûr nous lançons
l'alliance populaire le 14 avril et nous
allons installer dans toute la france
des collectifs de l'alliance populaire
queiroz 14 avril voilà et qui
convergeront le 3 décembre dans une
grande convention nationale de
l'alliance populaire alors concrètement
l'avion skoczylas qu'est ce que c'est
qu'ils y participera est-ce que les
écologistes en feront partie est ce que
les communistes en font partie
sinon est-ce que c'est pas une base un
peu étriqué pour pour rassembler en vue
de 2017
alors je crois qu'il ne faut pas
confondre l'alliance populaire et la
stratégie d'union de la gauche
l'alliance populaire c'est un
regroupement qui vise à dépasser le
parti c'est à la liste l'orient n'est
pas du tout la gauche mais ça n'a
strictement rien à voir
ti vise à dépasser le parti socialiste
qui prend acte du fait que toutes les
formations politiques sont confrontés à
des difficultés à gauche et qui vise à
se tourner aujourd'hui vers les citoyens
les associations citoyennes
les syndicalistes paraît qu'on leur
donne un exemple que pour vous pourriez
le site et de deux personnalités ou
d'associations qui pourrait faire
attendre on le 14 avril pour donner qui
en fera partie mais vous verrez qu'il y
aura plus dans cet appel 2
citoyens non encartés que de gens
entièreté parce que il faut aujourd'hui
construire un mouvement
je me laisse aller finalement pas
simplement le parti ça existe le parti
socialiste sort à la haye le parti
socialiste malgré ces difficultés reste
et de loin en termes organisationnel et
en terme électoral le parti principal
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que les tenants
de la primaire volt le parti socialiste
organise parce que au passage il faut
soixante mille personnes pour organiser
une primaire 1 il n'y a pas beaucoup de
partis qui sont ya pas le faire il faut
quelques moyens financiers j'observe
aujourd'hui que les tenants de notre
primaire donc que 2500 personnes qui se
sont portées volontaires donc c'est vrai
que j'ai maintenant si on veut le parti
socialiste pourra réaliser la primaire
il faut que des conditions il ya
quelqu'un dont on peut on parle beaucoup
et qu'on voit c'est peu c'est arnaud
montebourg il il ya quelques jours
surtout tard vous adressiez un 6e au
leader des frondeurs du ps christian
paul vous écriviez il serait plus loyal
et honnête que c'est que pour ses amis
que christian paul avoue qu'il renonce à
thomas piketty qui est l'un des
initiateurs
on le sait de la primaire et veut
montebourg qu'est ce que vous insinuez
par là est ce que vous insinuez que les
frondeurs du ps sont en train de
préparer l'atterrissage d'arnaud
montebourg en vue de 2017 est ce que
c'est a pas du tout pas du tout parce
que alors qu'ils doivent le dire je vais
vous expliquer si vous avez twitter
c'est compliqué vous avez raison
toujours impressionnant j'ai mal compris
une arme qu'est ce que je dis je dis
simplement que les fêtes christian paul
s'était prononcé pour piketty à cette
primaire et qu'il me semble que
aujourd'hui sa proximité historique et
s'approche lui ce budget actuel avec
arnaud montebourg
la mène plutôt à être du côté de d'un
nombre mais je ne dis pas que c'est la
gauche du parti socialiste qui prépare
cela puisque j'ai vu que marie noëlle
lienemann sénatrice avait déposé sa
candidature et benoît hamon était
favorable simplement jeudi gérard
filoche je viens de répondre oui à une
demande d'un des des internautes en leur
disant qu'ils étaient favorables à sa
candidature
et ainsi de suite donc je dis essaie de
faire le tri chez vous un candidat
unique du parti socialiste a
primaires si jamais elle se tient ça
nous le déciderons en temps et en heure
mais débat le parti socialiste non le
parti socialiste a décidé sa forme de
participation eh bien ce sera le mot de
la fin merci beaucoup jean christophe
cambadélis
merci si jim déjà remercie